okay I have a vector V that's a member
of RN so it's got n components in it so
v1 v2 all the way down to VN I've
touched on the idea but before but now
that we've seen what a transpose is and
we've taken transposes of matrices
there's no reason why we can't take the
transpose of a vector or a column vector
in this case so what would be transpose
look like well if you think of this as a
n by 1 matrix which it is it has n rows
and 1 column then what are we going to
get we're going to have a 1 by n matrix
when you take the transpose of it and
this one column is going to turn into
the 1 row so you're going to have it be
equal to v1 v2 all the way to V N and
you might remember we've already touched
on this and a lot of matrices before and
a lot of matrices let's say that some
matrix a we called the row vectors of
those matrix we call them the transpose
of some column vectors a transpose a 1
transpose a 2 transpose all the way down
to a n transpose is in fact not so many
videos ago I had those row vectors and I
could have just called them the
transpose of column vectors just like
that and that would have been in some
ways a better way to do it because we've
defined all these operations around
column vectors so you could always refer
to the transpose of the transpose and
then do some operations on them but
anyway I don't want to get too diverted
but let's think a little bit of what
happens when you operate this vector or
you take some operation of this vector
with some other vectors so let's say I
have another vector here that's W and
it's also a member of RN so if you have
w1 w2 all the way down to WN there's a
couple of things that we're already I
think reasonably familiar with you can
take the dot product of V and W V dot W
is equal to what it is equal to v1 times
w1 v1 w1 plus v2 w2 plus v2 w2 and you
just keep going all the way to VN
w n this is the definition of the dot
product of two column vectors now how
can we relate that to maybe the
transpose of V well we could take we
could take the transpose of V let me
write it this way what is if I've you
did a matrix multiplication so I did v1
v2 all the way to VN so this is V
transpose that's V transpose and I take
the product of that with W I take the
product of that with W so I have w1 w2
all the way down to WN now if I view
these as just matrices this is W right
here I view these just as matrices is
this matrix matrix product well-defined
see over here I have a N by 1 matrix n
by 1 matrix here I have a 1 sorry here
the first one I have is a 1 by n matrix
I have one row and n columns and here I
have an N by 1 matrix I have n rows and
only one column so this is well-defined
I have the same number of columns here
as I have rows here and I'm going this
is going to result in a one by one
matrix and what's it going to look like
it's going to be equal to V 1 times W 1
V 1 times W 1 let me write it like this
V 1 W 1 plus V 2 W 2 it's going to only
going to have one entry we could write
it as say just a 1 by 1 matrix like that
let me just do it one by one matrix like
that V 1 W 1 plus V 2 W 2 let me just I
could write V 2 there plus all the way
to VN WN that's it'll be it'll just be a
1 by 1 matrix that looks like that but
you might notice that these two things
are equivalent so we can make the
statement we can make a statement that V
dot W V dot W which is the same thing as
WD these things are equivalent to V dot
W is equivalent of let me just write it
once over here V dot double
you is the same thing as the transpose
of V V transpose times W times W as just
a matrix matrix product so if your view
V is a matrix take its transpose and
then just take that matrix and take the
product of that with W it's the same
thing as V dot W so that's an
interesting take way I guess you could
argue somewhat obvious and we've already
been referring this do you know when I
define matrix matrix products I kind of
said you're taking the dot product of
each row with each column and you can
see that it really is it's really the
dot product of the transpose of that row
with each column but you got the general
idea but let's see if we can build on
this a little bit let's say I have some
let's say I have some matrix a let me
save our little outcome that I have
there let's say I have some we get a
good color here let's say I have some
matrix a and it's an M by n matrix it's
an M by n matrix now if I were to
multiply that times a vector X so I'm
going to multiply it by some vector X
you can let's say that X is a member X
is a member right this way X is a member
of RN so it has n elements or another
way you could view it is it's an N by 1
matrix now when I take the product of
these what am I going to get or another
way to say it is what is the vector ax
when I take this product I'm just going
to get another vector what's it going to
be it's going to be an M by 1 vector
this is going to be an M by 1 vector so
we could say that ax is a member of our
M it's going to have M elements right if
this was equal to if you said that ax is
equal to I don't know let's say it's
equal to Z Z would have M elements you
would have you would have Z 1 Z 2 all
the way down to Z M and I know that
because you have M rows in a and you
have only one oh you could say this is
this is M by n this is n by one you can
the the resulting product will be M by
one or it'll be a vector that is a
member of
our M it will have exactly M elements
now if that's a vector of our M then the
idea of dotting this with another member
of our M is well-defined so let's say
that I have another member of our M
let's say I have a vector Y let's say Y
is also a member of RM this has a the
vector a X the vector that you get when
you take this product as M elements this
has m elements so the idea of taking
there dot product is well-defined let me
write that so we could take ax take
that's a vector and now we are dotting
with we are dotting it with this vector
right here and we'll get a number we
just take each of their terms multiply
the corresponding terms add them all up
and you get their dot product but what
is what is this equal to what is this
equal to we can just use this little I
guess you could call a day a result that
we got earlier on in this video using
this result the dot product of two
matrices or the sorry the dot product of
two vectors is equal to is equal to the
transpose of the first vector as kind of
a matrix so you can view this as a X
transpose this was a this is a M by 1
this is M by 1 this is M by 1 now this
is now a 1 by M matrix and now we can
multiply one by M matrix times y times y
just like that now what is this thing
equal to what is this thing equal to we
saw a while ago I think it was two or
three videos ago we saw that if we take
the product of two matrices and take its
transpose that's equal to the reverse
product of the transposes you just
switch the order and then take the
transposes so this is going to be equal
to this purple part is going to be equal
to X transpose X transpose times 8
transpose times y times y this is just
matrix products these are matrix
products these aren't necessarily vector
operations we're treating all of these
vectors
matrices and of course we're treating
the matrix as a matrix so what is this
equal to well we know that matrix
products are associative you could put a
parenthesis you know right now we have a
parenthesis around there from there but
we could we could just take another
Association we could say that that is
equal to that is equal to X transpose
times these two matrices times each
other this this is a vector but you can
represent it as an M by one matrix so
times a transpose a transpose Y a
transpose Y just like that now let's
think about what a transpose Y is let's
think about it
a transpose we have here a is M by n a
is M by n what is a transpose a
transpose is going to be n by M right
it's going to be an N by M so this is an
N by n M and then what is this vector Y
going to be this is an M this is an M by
one so when you take this product you're
going to get an N by one matrix or you
could imagine this as a vector that is a
member of our n so this is a member of
RN the entire product is going to result
with a vector that's a member of RN and
of course it's well-defined because this
is a 1 1 by n vector right there now we
can go back to our identity we have the
transpose of some vector times some
other vector they have the same well I
guess you could say this has set as many
horizontal entries as this guy has
vertical entries just like that so what
is this equal to we just use that
identity this is equal to they're just
regular x in this case instead of X
transpose we'll just have X so this is
equal to X X dot remember we just
untranslated view it that way dot a
transpose Y a transpose Y which is a
pretty neat outcome we got this being
equal to that we can kind of change the
associativity although we have to
essentially but change the order a bit
and and take the transpose of our matrix
so let me rewrite that just so that you
can remember the outcomes are the two
big outcomes of this video are I'll
rewrite this one up here V dot W is
equal to the matrix product of V
transpose times W and if I have some
matrix assume all of these matrix vector
products are well-defined and all the
dot products from L define if I have a X
dot y dot Y some other vector Y this is
equivalent to this is equivalent to X
dot you get essentially putting the a
with the other vector a transpose times
y and this just might be a useful
outcome or a useful result that we could
build upon later in the linear algebra
playlist